[Music]
this is syria's reality after a decade
of war
lines outside bakeries offering
subsidized bread
show the deepening economic crisis the
worst since the conflict began
the local currency has crashed it
affected the price of food
and basic goods the u.n says 60 percent
of the population or more than 12
million people
do not have regular access to food
the salary of a government employee is
worth around 15
many people are eating just bread and
dried wheat meat is a luxury
there is hunger and there is anger at
the regime but people can't do anything
bashar al-assad may not have recaptured
every inch of syria as he promised
but he survives the war with the help of
russia and iran
and the syrian president who has been in
power for more than two decades
is preparing for elections in the coming
weeks before his seven-year term
expires he's ignoring calls for a u.n
supervised vote
and the opposition is not surprised
the new american administration that
they didn't mention syria at all issues
from the eu statement there's no
missions here at all
so i think he's sending the message or
he benefiting from the message that
i'm staying as long as you you there's
no act so why why to give up
if nobody wants to act against me
the syrian government and its allies are
under western sanctions for their role
in the war
the sanctions have stopped the flow of
money needed for reconstruction
and the hope assad will agree to
political reforms
but even when the balance of power was
against assad he refused to cooperate
with the u.n led peace process
doing so would ultimately weaken his
grip on power
with no settlement in sight at least 13
million people remain in exile
within and beyond syria's borders it's a
central issue of the conflict
many say there can't be a settlement or
reconciliation with more than half of
the country
displaced the syrian government has
actually put in place
laws and policies that are designed to
keep syrian refugees out or at the very
least
send them a message that they're not
wanted there from laws that deal with
property confiscation to laws requiring
acid seizures if they don't pay
exorbitant amounts
to avoid military conscription the front
lines have been largely quiet for a year
there is a stalemate with much of the
north and northeast outside the state's
control
assad may boast about controlling
two-thirds of syria but it's
increasingly being described as a failed
state with no international
legitimacy al-jazeera beirut